This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. There comes a time in the life of a modern city, where it begins to grow up. Literally, ever since bridge frames were upended into soaring towers, and elevators were equipped with reliable safety breaks, if there are a lot of people in one place, it just makes sense for us to stack ourselves on top of each other. Santiago, the capital of Chile, has been going through a tremendous growth spurt since its economic boom of the mid-1990s. It happened fast. In just a few years, single-family homes all over the city were replaced with high rises. It's Daniel Arcon. He's an award-winning author and host of Radio Amelante.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。现代城市的发展过程中，总会迎来一个开始“长大”的时刻。从字面上看，自从桥梁框架被竖立成高耸的塔楼，电梯配备了可靠的安全制动装置以来，如果一个地方聚集了大量人口，我们向上堆叠居住就变得顺理成章。智利首都圣地亚哥自20世纪90年代中期经济繁荣以来，一直经历着惊人的增长。这一切发生得很快。短短几年内，全市的单户住宅就被高层建筑所取代。这是丹尼尔·阿隆，他是屡获殊荣的作家，也是《Radio Ambulante》节目的主持人。
I have a friend in Santiago named Rodrigo Rojas. Well, hello, my name is Rodrigo. Rodrigo played a small part in Santiago's upward mobility, which wouldn't be that remarkable if he were an engineer or a real estate developer or an architect or something like that, but he isn't. Rodrigo Rojas is a poet. And I'm a literary professor, a right poetry. So the thing about Chile is that everyone is a poet. And I'm a literary professor, a right poetry. So the thing about Chile is that everyone is a poet. I don't know if you've read Bologna,
我在圣地亚哥有个朋友叫罗德里戈·罗哈斯。你好，我叫罗德里戈。罗德里戈在圣地亚哥的向上流动中扮演了一个小角色，如果他是一名工程师、房地产开发商或建筑师之类的，这并不稀奇，但他不是。罗德里戈·罗哈斯是一位诗人。我是一名文学教授，写诗。智利的情况是，每个人都是诗人。我不知道你是否读过波拉尼奥，
but it's like poets are Chile's superheroes. So do you write any poetry? No, man, I'm Peruvian. This is the story of how Rojas' poetry altered the physical shape of Santiago's rapidly changing skyline. This is how it worked. A developer bought an old house, tore it down, had an architect drop plans for a high rise,
但诗人就像智利的超级英雄。那你写诗吗？不，伙计，我是秘鲁人。这就是罗哈斯的诗歌如何改变圣地亚哥快速变化的天际线形态的故事。它是这样运作的：开发商买下一栋旧房子，拆掉它，让建筑师画出高层建筑的蓝图，
and then Rodrigo stepped in. And my job consisted on a very simple thing. I had to give a name to the building. He worked early in the mornings, and his job was like this. He had to get into people's heads. I had to walk around a lot, know the different neighborhoods, and see what characteristics that neighborhood had, and what characteristics would the people who could buy those apartments
然后罗德里戈介入了。我的工作很简单。我必须给这栋建筑起个名字。他清晨就开始工作，他的工作是这样的：他必须钻进人们的脑子里。我必须四处走动，了解不同的社区，看看那个社区有什么特点，以及那些能买得起这些公寓的人，
would be looking for in that neighborhood. So people aspired to be something else. They wanted to have a better life. So they had a dream. And I had to walk around the neighborhoods thinking about what kind of dream that person was looking for. And I had to devise a name for that dream. A Drigo worked for a public relations firm. It's one of ten or so in Santiago that we're doing this kind of thing. As far as I know, no other firm had a poet on staff.
在那个社区会寻找什么样的特征。人们渴望成为别样的人。他们想要更好的生活。所以他们有一个梦想。我必须在社区里走来走去，思考那个人在寻找什么样的梦想。我必须为那个梦想构思一个名字。罗德里戈在一家公关公司工作。这是圣地亚哥大约十家做这类事情的公司之一。据我所知，没有其他公司有专职诗人。
Rodrigo was in school at the time working three jobs to support himself and his family. And in the course of a little over a year, he named more than 40 buildings all over the capital. Basically, dozens of little poems he wrote are now embedded into the design of his city. Well, to be honest, I wouldn't confess this in Spanish. You see, I don't feel quite proud, although you might consider it as you suggest my first publications. Very short poems.
罗德里戈当时还在上学，打三份工来养活自己和家人。在一年多的时间里，他为首都的40多栋建筑命名。基本上，他写的几十首小诗现在都嵌入了他所在城市的设计中。说实话，我不会用西班牙语承认这一点。你看，我并不感到自豪，尽管你可能会认为这是我最初的出版物。非常短的诗。
But I think, no, now I'm listening to myself, as I speak. I think it is a story that should be told, because it's a story of dreams of people. Proud or not, he wrote hundreds of building-name poems. He conjured the names from myths, from history, from literature, and he even did some field research. One time, he had the name of few buildings going up near Santiago's Polo Club, but there was a catch. He couldn't use the words polo or club.
但我认为，不，现在我听着自己说话，我觉得这是一个应该被讲述的故事，因为这是一个关于人们梦想的故事。无论是否自豪，他写了数百首建筑命名诗。他从神话、历史、文学中构思名字，甚至做了一些实地调查。有一次，他要为圣地亚哥马球俱乐部附近正在兴建的几栋建筑命名，但有一个陷阱。他不能使用“马球”或“俱乐部”这两个词。
So he snuck into a party there to look for just the right name. The first thing that I learned is that you don't dress up for polo because if you dress up, you're just trying too hard. But of course, coming up with names was just half the job. The other half was negotiating with developers. I would choose the best ten and given a speech of what characteristics or what kind of dreams were behind
于是他溜进那里的一场派对，寻找最合适的名字。我学到的第一件事是，你不能为了马球而刻意打扮，因为如果你刻意打扮，就显得太用力了。当然，想出名字只是工作的一半。另一半是与开发商谈判。我会选出最好的十个，并发表一番演讲，说明这些名字背后有什么样的特征或什么样的梦想，
each of these ten names and they would, I know, they would yon. Until he said their own name. They say, well, and it can also be called Don Jorge. So, wow, that's great. So, yeah, not poetry that will win awards, necessarily. But like all good poetry, some of his work could be transformative. There's this one neighborhood, Eliano, that's particularly cold and humid. Thanks to Rodrigo, it now has buildings that make it seem almost tropical. He imagined that to forget the weather, residents might sit on their balconies,
他们会，我知道，他们会打哈欠。直到他说出他们自己的名字。他们说，嗯，它也可以叫唐·豪尔赫。哇，太棒了。所以，是的，这不一定是能获奖的诗歌。但像所有好的诗歌一样，他的一些作品具有变革性。有一个叫埃利亚诺的社区，特别阴冷潮湿。多亏了罗德里戈，它现在有了让它看起来几乎像热带地区的建筑。他想象着为了忘记天气，居民们可能会坐在阳台上，
staring at the slate-gray sky and dream of beaches. So for names. Cancun uno, cancun dos, cancun tres, cancun cuadro. The fifth one, I couldn't pull it off. And the developers were so excited about this. They bought palm trees and planted them in front of the building. I take it, there aren't huge groves of palm trees in Santiago. No, there are not.
盯着灰蒙蒙的天空，梦想着海滩。所以名字是：坎昆一号、坎昆二号、坎昆三号、坎昆四号。第五个，我没能成功。开发商对此非常兴奋。他们买了棕榈树，种在建筑前面。我想，圣地亚哥没有大片的棕榈树林吧？不，没有。
It's not a natural thing to have palm trees. In Santiago, we have a Mediterranean climate who are not a Caribbean country. Still, the cancunns were some of the first buildings in the area and they sold really well. So the other developers followed suit. So there's a whole neighborhood with names of islands and beaches. It looks like Hawaii or something like that.
在圣地亚哥拥有棕榈树并不是自然的事。我们是地中海气候，不是加勒比国家。尽管如此，“坎昆”系列是该地区最早的建筑之一，而且卖得非常好。所以其他开发商也纷纷效仿。于是，整个社区都以岛屿和海滩命名。看起来就像夏威夷之类的。
He learned to read the tastes of his clients. The meetings were usually in the office of the developer, which gave me a lot of information of what he wanted to be seen as in society. One time he went to a developer's office that was just lousy with Greek columns. Very tacky. Lots of imitation of marble and everything had a Greek column, even like Greek columns in order to get to the bathroom. So when they sat down to talk names, Rodrigo abandoned all the research he had done going
他学会了解读客户的品味。会议通常在开发商的办公室里进行，这让我了解了很多他想在社会上被视为怎样的人。有一次，他去了一家开发商的办公室，里面到处都是希腊柱。非常俗气。大量的仿大理石，每样东西都有希腊柱，甚至去洗手间都要经过希腊柱。所以当他们坐下来讨论名字时，罗德里戈放弃了他之前做的所有研究，
in. And he said, how would you like the building called Athena's? That's Athens. Oh yes. Sparta. Oh yes. Even there's a building called Olympiolas. Everything is in Greek sound again. And he said, oh you, you're so creative. How do you come up with this?
他说，你觉得把这栋楼叫“雅典娜”怎么样？那是雅典。哦，是的。斯巴达。哦，是的。甚至还有一栋楼叫“奥林匹亚”。一切又都是希腊语发音。他说，哦，你太有创意了。你是怎么想出来的？
I've been working on this for a long time. It was so creative. How do you come up with this? Never. No, I've been working on this for a long time. It was so funny. Rodrigo even fabricated whole stories in the service of building and identity. He came up with one story about a ship called the San Sibar. The Zanzibar, no. San Sibar was a ship built along with the Titanic, but was slightly smaller. But the San Sibar never sank.
我为此工作了很长时间。这太有创意了。你是怎么想出来的？从来没有。不，我为此工作了很长时间。这太搞笑了。罗德里戈甚至为了建立身份认同而编造了整个故事。他编了一个关于一艘叫“圣西巴尔”号的船的故事。桑给巴尔，不。圣西巴尔是一艘与泰坦尼克号一起建造的船，但稍微小一点。但圣西巴尔从未沉没。
Never had an accident, survived to wars and it was always known as a discreet but very luxurious life. And they really liked that, it all sounds so elegant. It worked so well, he used it again and again and again. He actually can't even remember how many times he used the same trick. Yeah, I can't remember at this time, I think I made up Sancébère. I made up Normandie, which is a French name. I say, well, this was the competition of the Titanic. It's always the same story. It's a ship built with the Titanic and it survives.
从未发生过事故，在两次战争中幸存下来，一直以低调但非常奢华的生活而闻名。他们真的很喜欢这个，听起来很优雅。这招太管用了，他一次又一次地使用它。他甚至记不清自己用了多少次同样的把戏。是的，我记不清了，我想我编造了圣西巴尔。我编造了诺曼底，这是一个法国名字。我说，嗯，这是泰坦尼克号的竞争对手。总是同一个故事。这是一艘与泰坦尼克号一起建造并幸存下来的船。
And the thing that when you mix luxury with survival of tragedies, that's very important for Chile because that's the search of status and the survival of earthquakes. And if a developer rubbed him the wrong way, he'd sneak in a joke. There's a building in Santiago named Infantes de Carrón, which sounds nice, even noble. Infantes means children of kings in Spanish. And Carrón has the carrion, which sounds nice, even noble. Infantist means children of kings in Spanish. And carrion has the double r, which gives it a prestige.
当你把奢华与灾难中的幸存结合起来时，这对智利来说非常重要，因为这是对地位的追求和对地震的幸存。如果开发商让他不爽，他就会偷偷开个玩笑。圣地亚哥有一栋建筑叫“卡里翁的孩子”，听起来不错，甚至很高贵。在西班牙语中，“Infantes”意为国王的孩子。而“Carrion”有双R，这赋予了它一种威望。
Sure it does. And let's you know that the Infantist carrion are villains in El Mio's Sid, one of the most famous epic poems in the Spanish language. And these are not just any villains. They were real bastards, they raped a girl in the book. So it's not really something that you would be proud of, but the developer. He really liked it. And in that session, he wasn't accepting any single name. And I was angry and I said, okay, you might as well call it, losing fantas, the career
确实如此。而且你要知道，“卡里翁的孩子”是《熙德之歌》中的反派，这是西班牙语中最著名的史诗之一。他们不仅仅是普通的反派。他们是真正的混蛋，他们在书中强奸了一个女孩。所以这并不是你会引以为豪的事情，但开发商。他真的很喜欢它。在那次会议上，他不接受任何名字。我很生气，我说，好吧，你不如叫它“卡里翁的孩子”，
and I said, yes, that's what I want. So there is a building named after these rapists. Name after some rapists. Yeah, some rapists. But yeah, though, literally rapists. But when he wasn't tricking his clients, Rodrigo was interpreting dreams. And that's important because he was naming buildings
我说，是的，这就是我想要的。所以有一栋建筑是以这些强奸犯的名字命名的。以强奸犯的名字命名？是的，一些强奸犯。但确实，字面上是强奸犯。但当他不捉弄客户时，罗德里戈是在解读梦想。这很重要，因为他是在为那些
that hadn't been built yet. There were nothing but drawings on a piece of paper. Choosing the name was the last step before the brochures could be printed up. And those brochures were what the buyers took to the bank when they asked for a loan. If enough apartments were sold, the building went up. If not, the project was abandoned.
还没建成的建筑命名。它们只是一张纸上的图纸。选择名字是印刷宣传册之前的最后一步。而这些宣传册是买家在申请贷款时带到银行的东西。如果卖出的公寓足够多，建筑就会建起来。如果没有，项目就会被放弃。
And the entire city was remade this way. Families taking a chance on imaginary buildings with made up names. The same process repeated thousands of times in hundreds of neighborhoods, husbands and wives, looking at a picture, reading a poem, and taking a chance. And Rodrigo did the same thing.
整个城市就是这样被重塑的。家庭在虚构的建筑和编造的名字上冒险。同样的过程在数百个社区重复了数千次，丈夫和妻子看着图片，读着诗，然后冒险。罗德里戈也做了同样的事情。
He lives in one of these buildings now. Although, unfortunately, the name of his building was decidedly lacking in imagination. He owns an apartment on Cayet, Chile, España, in the district of Núñoa, in a building called. It was called Chile, España. So I bought a redundant building. But so what if it's redundant? It's a name, and names are how the anonymity of a place is dulled.
他现在就住在一栋这样的建筑里。尽管不幸的是，他那栋楼的名字实在缺乏想象力。他在努尼奥阿区的智利西班牙街拥有一套公寓，在一栋叫……它叫“智利西班牙”。所以我买了一栋冗余的建筑。但冗余又怎样？它是一个名字，名字是消除地方匿名性的方式。
It's how we push back. Every building has the name exhibited usually in bronze. And if it has a concert, they shine it every day. No one says I live in that rectangle of port concrete over there. No, they say things like I live in Cancun Quatro, I live in Don Jorge. I live in the San Sibar named after a ship as luxurious as the Titanic. And no, you've never heard of it because it never sank. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Daniel Alocón from Maradio Ambulante with Sam Green
这是我们反击的方式。每栋建筑的名字通常都用青铜展示。如果有门房，他们每天都会擦亮它。没有人说我住在那个长方形的混凝土块里。不，他们会说我住在坎昆四号，我住在唐·豪尔赫。我住在圣西巴尔，以一艘像泰坦尼克号一样豪华的船命名。不，你没听说过它，因为它从未沉没。《99%隐形》本周由来自《Radio Ambulante》的丹尼尔·阿隆与萨姆·格林制作，
Span and me Roman Mars. It's a project of 91.7, local public radio, KALW in San Francisco, and the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook. I tweet at Roman Mars, but right now we have links to Radio Ambalante, which builds itself as this American life in Spanish. There's a couple stories in English, but mainly it's in Spanish. So if you speak Spanish, you are in luck, my friend. And if you don't speak Spanish, I bet this is not the first time that you are filled with regret about the choices you've made in your life.
以及我和罗曼·马斯。这是旧金山91.7地方公共广播电台KALW和旧金山美国建筑师协会的一个项目。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞这个节目。我在Twitter上是@RomanMars，但现在我们有《Radio Ambulante》的链接，它自称是西班牙语版的《美国生活》。里面有几个英语故事，但主要是西班牙语。所以如果你会说西班牙语，你很幸运，我的朋友。如果你不会说西班牙语，我敢打赌这肯定不是你第一次为你生活中所做的选择感到后悔。
If I don't more at 99%invisible.org Find out more at 99%invisible.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
更多信息请访问 99percentinvisible.org。本集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。